say hello to Frank Caliendo
comedian/actor Impressionists you can
see Frank at the Irvine improv may 2nd
you'll be at the Seneca Niagara casino
May 17th
go to Frank on stage calm longtime
friend of the show good to see you you
surprised me I was not ready for that
star I thought that was the spot you had
some carpeting down yeah and I thought
carpeting a little mini rug taped down
and I thought that's where people stood
to when the camera came to you and then
you lifted that up and my name was there
and I almost got teary I didn't get
teary eyed like but I got real close but
it's a walk of fame we wanted to have a
Walk of Fame a red carpet of people who
have been instrumental in you know
developing this show helping this show
for the last decade you've been in the
studio a few times yeah and Al Michaels
is there we got Reggie Miller on there
Bryan Cranston Will Ferrell Patrick
Ewing Chrissy Teigen a lot of people
yeah more famous than me exactly is this
the greatest moment of your life this is
uh you know what yes better than my
wedding better than my ten children
being born this is it Dan you've really
figured out how to get to the highest
peak of my life also like we were
wondering this that you could really
mess people up on draft day if you
wanted to okay so there it sounds like a
setup for a bit but here's this is this
is true and I didn't talk to you about
this at all there's no set up so I'm
calling Steve Kim or texting Steve time
audio messages before so I've before the
draft about four hours before the draft
because once the draft got closed I
didn't hear from him for hours right so
the GM of the Cardinals so I'm sending
Steve kind messages from Jon Gruden I'll
tell you what man I love you brother I
got an idea how about you draft
how about you draft somebody else at
number one and I how about you draft
Joey Bosa at number one and now I'll
draft Tyler Murray at number four we'll
make a trade
I'd give you my 27th pick you give me a
second rounder we have the best rate
ever man I think it works out for both
teams so then he got that and then he
sent it on to some other field I called
him up as Jay Glazer to I was like you
know
there's unbelievable stuff going on and
I you can't do Jay Glazer without
swearing every five seconds as FSF that
you know you got and then shefter I had
I called a shefter and the chef I'm like
listen I hear you're talking to both Ian
Rapoport and Jay Glazer and I just
wanted you know my phone is on and if
you ever need to talk to me I'll be here
wherever I am in a chair sitting
perfectly upright and prepared and then
Steve sent that on Decca tuned to
Schefter and then shefter text me look
what I got from Steve guy what are you
doing
so chapter who always says I just don't
hear myself when you're talking is me
I'm not sure if it's right but it's but
it's perfect but I I think most people
react that way don't think some do
Sunday it's funny how close some voices
are cuz shefter with a cold is Ian
Rapoport no why but they're the same guy
that's I if you have that cadence you
become an NFL insider let your Jay glaze
you and Jay glaze is it you want to work
out let's work out good way to work out
you know I'm gonna do on my way to work
out there to work out double work out do
you think I could play Ram man and
he-man the movie might even have a neck
I don't know if many people are doing
Ian Rapoport though I mean it's very
niche yeah but if you think if you think
Adam Schefter snitch and no chef teah
though is it's the Simpsons world that's
what this I've pigeon-holed myself at
this point I'm actually doing Adam
Schefter while trying not to do it
I've actually pigeonhole myself in a lot
of ways into doing all these sports
impressions that are so niche like
nobody-nobody
outside of the sports world knows Mel
Kiper jr. you know the the whole pop and
here's every time I see McShea he's like
you've ruined my life I'm like why he's
all I hear is todd todd they didn't know
your name before i did that you were the
other guy with Count Chocula but my
audience the sports audience each this
absolutely yeah that people get it
that's I do some weird ones too like
like I I go to just a mess Rich Eisen
show up
I will whose good friend right yeah so I
can mention it yeah but I'll just go on
and do Steve Mariucci hands that's the
whole thing is this does
and I'm real-life chris farley back you
missing things up here that's an
American yeah alright we're back
Steve crime is joining us the your good
friend the Arizona yeah yeah hey Steve
hey how we doing guys how did you put up
with Frank on draft day at least prior
to the draft with all these he prank
phone calls turned his phone off well I
mean is this really Dan or well I could
be Dan and Jim Rome asking you questions
great is this it was torture I felt like
I did three or four trades with the
Raiders and I was calm like man how long
have you guys known each other
probably six seven years something like
that cuz Lancer line out of Houston who
works in a foul network and so his dad
was coaching with he was a line coach
for the Cardinals and he was on a plane
he says I text Lance I go is this your
dad and a picture of him he's like yeah
so I ended up getting to meet Steve
through that and the Cardinals facility
is on the same street I live on it's
just three blocks down which took like
three miles or something like that I
came in and just met with Steve and it
was kicked off it was a lot of fun it
was a it was incredible and he's he's
always saying do you know how many
people know you I'm like I'm a big deal
man yeah but you're also Packer fan
aren't you well I'm Steve as lured me
I'm gonna be a huge Cuyler Murray fan no
oh absolutely huge I'm getting away on
board I'll always be a Packer fan
somewhat but because I grew up there but
here's the thing I I like being friends
with an NFL GM so I'm gonna be alright
let me get some business out of the way
with Steve unless you want to grill him
on no you're better okay your Prime when
did you decide what was the reason why
you decided on Cuyler Murray when you
did Steve well I think you just because
it you know we had the time and then
we wanted to go through the process
there was no reason to speed it up and
you know once you can take in all the
information not only from your coaches
and your Scouts and all the due
diligence we did on the University of
Oklahoma campus I think at the end of
the day it became crystal clear you know
probably the week before that Tyler was
that was the guy but was there something
there that you solved if you hadn't made
up your mind prior to the draft what was
it that you were hesitating on or that
you finally convinced yourself and
everybody else that that was the right
guy well you know I think it's my job to
to really look at the big picture which
is you know it's feeling out whether
Josh Rosen plus you know a defensive
player is better than them Tyler Murray
and potential trade value so I mean at
the end of the day we really just had
look at the big picture and it was just
hard too hard to pass Tyler up just
because of the dominating traits that he
has the skill set the things that I feel
like he can do on the field to make us a
better offense there was no doubt that
to me he's the guy that catapults this
organization moving forward anybody try
to blow your doors off with trying to
get that number one pick well Frank
Caliendo played his Jon Gruden was
probably the yes oh I got but you know
at the end of the day there wasn't
enough enough of a market to get us to
come off of trading or drafting Tyler
here's the funny thing before you go in
with another question I've never heard
him talk in this cadence to me before
this is his cadence is something
completely it's bad or anything but it's
just you've never said the way you're
speaking right now I've never felt that
like I coached the flag football team
with this son he's like well what you're
doing right now seems to be your outside
there's never in your time and I'm well
versed in hearing this and understanding
what if we were together and the
microphone wasn't on and then I asked
these questions I'm gonna get probably a
little better coaching if I didn't put
Carson in enough yeah what's going on
here right now we're not seeing enough
I'm saying I want to be an involved
parent I'm not that right now
because I usually step aside sit on my
lawn chair and you know check texts from
players who are worried about different
things you have no idea how many I've
never seen a guy on his phone more than
Steve time it's like I'm like one
shefter well yeah chef tees up there
he's got double but it's the look on
Kimes face like chef teah gets stuff and
it's always like it's like oh this is
good the offer for Josh Rosen how many
teams did you hear from for Josh Rosen
the certainly the best partner was Miami
how many teams did you hear from we
talked to probably around five teams in
total I like what you did with the draft
I think Murphy out of Washington I I
think he starts right away you know
Thompson out of Alabama Butler out of
Iowa State I I think I think people
focus on the top part of the draft but
you win with those middle rounds those
late rounds and I think Arizona did a
really good job here Steve
yeah I think the one thing we want to
focus on Dan was playmakers and and
three of those receivers were in the top
eight I think they Andy Isabella was one
and then we had six and eight in terms
of receiving production and the NCAA
which again goes to show that those guys
are perimeter threats and and can
certainly and Andy Isabelle as a guy
that's got great speed can take the top
off and then mr. relevant was Caleb
Wilson out there UCLA and he led the
NCAA is a tight end and receiving yards
so a number of guys that I think can
help us can help us early also excited
about Zach Allen the defensive end from
from Boston College you in my time
scouting I don't think I've scouted a
defensive lineman who's had 100 tackles
well we appreciate your time as always I
look forward to talking you off the air
so then I can compare and contrast these
answers I'd say how good I thought there
is no way that Steve would call in and I
thank you very much for being that what
I almost did with him is I was called in
I'll tell you what man you know I would
take it number one
Xion
Arizona may get both calibre in Zion
we've had that man that would be
tremendous thank you Steve Steve guy
Arizona Cardinal to you that was funny
to me that cadence changed because he's
all he's very soft they all do it like
it they have to yeah because you have to
turn there's a switch you have to flip
on that you as a GM I've gotten to know
this too that not as a Jim but I talked
to knowing a few GM you know guys you
have to always be careful about what
you're saying you can't give away too
much you want to give away some peace
its relationships with the press and
stuff like I could never do it I would
just you got to work on your Dave
gentlemen yeah no Giants GM yeah but you
better hurry up I don't he's a care like
his voice yeah it feels like he's you
know every like John Schneider he's
doing Gruden to me like Schneider is
like like it's a little higher man
you're doing chunky I'm doing Chucky
there we go
if you were Jonah Hill did this Jonah
Hill growing up used to prank phone
calls to businesses and then he was
working on a character I believe wolf of
Wall Street where he would calling
Samsung and asking questions as if he
was you know consumer but he wanted
somebody to talk to to use the voice
have you ever pranked phone called you
know well years and years ago I pranked
a news station as John Madden and I just
said I it was when he was on Sunday
night for Monday Night Football
yeah I remember it was Sunday Night
Football right cuz he went to ABC it was
and I said I don't want to do this
anymore it was like are you drunk
yeah al michaels and standing on a box
and then they wanted to put me on the
air live and like I can't do this I will
get him so much trouble so I backed out
of it but not there were
I use my powers for good as opposed to
evil so but I have I have messed with
insiders and stuff I've messed with
Glaser or I miss with shefter years ago
calling him as Glaser as like a witness
retiring you can't believe this we're
retiring this is like five six seven
years ago I wait and then why would Jay
Glazer be calling him like that doesn't
compute I don't even think she after II
would say make sense that does not
compute my neural transmitters are
firing we'll take a break
Frank Caliendo where's Terry Bradshaw
would call you Frank Kelly didn't do
today would I I don't like him anymore
but I I still love him into pieces
did you think that Terry did not like
you on Fox it's like wrestling right
he'd always come it's like wrestling
right like your bad guy I'm a good guy
yeah that's exactly what it is let me
jump off the top turnbuckle Frank why
can't we just do a clothesline we'll
come back we'll continue with Frank
Caliendo also more phone calls best and
worst of the weekend Frank Caliendo here
in the man cave Franklin stage calm for
all the information on his stand-up tour
who did you admire growing up oh yeah
he's tired from the ping-pong I got
killed too
McLovin you're really good in ping-pong
I am with the proper equipment you don't
give Tiger Woods a bunch of tree
branches I look at my Twitter feed ask
him about the Twitter feed would I
because I was trying to spin the ball
like the paddle I have and it is kind of
cheating but everybody has it the paddle
I have is probably about $300 yeah and
it's made from I think vibranium and the
rubber on each size like $75 a word
vibranium no that's well it's it from
akanda it's a it's a Avengers reference
okay but yeah so I was I was out of
breath from that but he did you I think
he would beat me in like garage
table-tennis because I can't do any of
my special moves Dan it sounds like he's
doing an impersonation of someone making
excuses
I'm not doing an impression of it at all
I'm just making excuses in terms of GM's
and name dropping today I played Daryl
Morey a Darrell boy's a good table
tennis player crush him crush him
destroyed like to the point where he
thought about quitting and then only
being a GM for the Rockets who's the
best tennis table tennis player in the
world maybe ma long Jean GK these guys
that really that's it they're that it
was this guy named Waldner for years he
was a European guy but I'd say when you
play people that are at such a high
level like you try it you think you can
hit the ball but they know where the
ball is going before you and hit it and
then I was playing this guy named
loophole s qu and he was spinning the
ball his full name I'm not sure I just I
tried to spin he spuntz under spun the
ball so you have to try and lift it or
spin under to get it back and I tried to
lift it and he went no it's not that
you're going to do baby and what
happened I got to know why you can't
even you can't because they just spin
the ball and you don't think it's gonna
hit the table and all of a sudden it's
diving down it's those guys are so good
it's ridicu maybe you're like a color
commentator for table tennis yeah like
Fred Willard in the best best-in-show
yeah there was a ping-pong movie years
ago I was probably called pong or
something like that yeah but they sure
they probably did something that I think
I was trying to think of somebody good
to do that when I go back to the Grodin
or something like that they would he's
gonna he's gonna go for a short forehand
there right now flipped it that's a
banana flip Chiquita man who have you
heard recently where you go you know
what that might be somebody to invest in
maybe like a Tony Romo the excitement
he's just so excited about everything
you got to predict everything you got
yeah you have to know the future I don't
know why he's not on the draft just
doing all the predictions before you
know it's gonna be here so yeah I mean
you're brilliant at bringing people into
real life weed you know when you there's
the thing is you take them out of that
you do it's a formula really
and it's why I've been working on a lot
of stuff outside of the impression
because it does get so formulaic for me
but
like the it's the color commentator what
they do is they break down something in
a game we just take that and you break
down something in real life and then and
that formula seems to work for
everything cuz it's stuff that people
can relate to but you I saw there's list
here of your top ten impressions I'm
curious what you think your best
impression is because this is Morgan
Freeman at ten that's a good one side
coverage nine I don't know eight Stephen
Smith I have to say I'm incredulous in
this entire situation I understand
what's going on on the ping-pong table
the entire cast of Seinfeld what are you
talking about hey Jerry that's a good
one you don't do Elaine Al Pacino oh
yeah I remember that
Robin Williams that's weird cuz you do
that I do the Robin Williams I don't do
it in my act anymore and people will say
do some Robin Williams I'm like what's
gonna happen is all the women at all
yeah sorry Jon Gruden at number four
that's a good one man Charles Barkley
nebari that's what I'm talking about I
should have two stars Dave the
presidents George Bush and Bill Clinton
that's so who made this list these are
these are some old get all the new
impressions people get in trouble that's
the problem
[Music]
man yeah
like nobody ever puts Robert Downey jr.
okay there you go
do me a favor enjoy yourself Liam Neeson
got in trouble you can't do that anymore
he's gonna be interesting to see him in
men in black code the reactions gonna be
there which seems like he shouldn't even
be in that it's yes so it's I was
watching there's another one I was
watching a Chris Hemsworth and he's
gonna play Hulk Hogan have you seen that
and all we've ever heard him to is like
looky my brother like you imagine that
audition what that's like they're like
alright try it out Chris okay let me
tell you something
I know it's not quite there can dragon
alright I've got this and let me tell
you something brother now you're still
night no I've got it let me tell you
something brother I think that's it ok
one more time one more time let me tell
you something
let me tell you some brother you're
going to train say your prayers vitamins
like all those Hulkamania exact you got
the part but just work on it when you
are on an airplane you ever gotten
cornered where you just you can't escape
in terms of like people of knowing who I
am and then wanting you yeah then we got
a five-hour flight to LAX they're
usually pretty nice I was on this is the
most embarrassing thing I was on a
flight going to LAX and Aquaman was on
it Jason Momoa yeah and I don't know why
he was on that plane but people are
walking around but he was with his
family said nobody wanted to bother him
but I and every taken pictures of him he
catches me taking a picture of him and I
was like ah crap and then the worst part
was yeah and then he's like then we had
this great conversation she's
conversation because he was like and
then the flight attendant comes over to
me and she's like you're gonna erase
that correct I was like yeah I'm going
to which was a lie alright so then all
right now I have a picture of Jason
Momoa like telling me not to take a
picture of it and I want to go I'm
famous to kind of Frank on stage calm
Irvine Irvine this week and then Niagara
Falls Seneca Niagara in a couple weeks
thank you buddy
yeah thank you great to see you thank
you for stopping by the man cave for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at